hello everybody and welcome to another
1hour flipping challenge today we're
going to be doing one of the most
requested challenges probably uh since I
started and that is going to be doing 1
hour flipping clue Scrolls now this is
my third try doing this it's a good idea
but inherently most of the items do not
trade very frequently which leads uh it
to having very inconsistent results so
this one was obviously the the result
that ended the best so I hope hope you
enjoy and let's jump into it okay so
today we're going to be starting with 40
mil and we're going to be doing clue
scroll items only they're going to be
kind of hit and miss so we're probably
going to switch around a lot what items
we're doing uh we're going to see how it
goes and let's get started 60 minutes on
the clock let's go so to start off I
thought I would actually just go with
purple sweets uh it's actually the most
traded item uh of all the clue Scrolls
pretty much um they have about 100,000
Tred day so possibly we might actually
get a decent margin on these purple
suits um
275 to
2790 it's not that great but considering
there's no other items like it uh I'll
do a th000 next up I think we're going
to do the fury ornament kit uh is one of
the more highly traded items that have a
pretty high price tag with it uh so
we'll go ahead uh looks like they're
buying currently for about 296
60 uh yeah 2960 so Fury ornament
kit
2960 definitely going going to do one at
a time for all of these
items okay we got the fury ornament kit
let's move on to something else okay and
next up uh we're going to do some pages
uh now we're on tracker looking at the
Arad armadel page three uh has about a
100 to 200 traded a day which is okay uh
for the item now 469
503 let's have a look at the more recent
data here looks like going for about
406 and selling for
475 uh so we'll definitely go ahead and
do the armal page
three armadil page three and we'll toss
it in there
for
407k and uh maybe we'll try to snag
three of these pages and next up we're
going to do the armadil page 4 uh we
looked it up on G tracker it looks like
it has a pretty similar margin about 50
which is pretty good so we'll buy it for
364 is a Buy price and we'll sell it for
around
415 and uh we'll do four of those why
not and looks like we actually did get
an armor little page three uh which we
are going to be selling for what was it
again all right uh we'll pop it in there
for 475 and uh if it doesn't buy we'll
lower it down cuz that does seem like a
pretty hefty margin so we'll leave it in
there for a bit okay next up we're going
to try the wizard boots uh looks like
they're buying for about 550 something
oh and it looks like we actually sold
that armal page as well ah nice that is
70k in profit pretty decent uh but we're
going to do the wizard boot next
actually trades almost about 200 a day
which is pretty
decent um looks like it's up to
558 yeah
558k and we'll try to do five of these
or something so we do have quite a bit
of money to work with here and we
actually bought about half of our purple
Suite so far so pretty quick okay and
next up uh a of the Gods is something
that I have done in the past quite a bit
it looks like it has
a 200 GP margin on it which is pretty
good we'll go ahead and put an offering
for about
490 ale of the
Gods
491k and uh I we'll be ambitious and go
for two which seems kind of funny to say
that and yeah we still have 20 mil left
okay so we still have not found an item
but we did end up buying the fury
ornament kit now I do not remember what
we were planning on selling that for
again uh we may have to go open up G
tracker again okay so we bought for
2960 I think we're hoping to sell it for
I don't
know put in for 3050
and hopefully that will sell soon on top
of that we also did get another armor
page three which we hopefully sell for
475 again uh getting a pretty decent
margin there
475 pop that into sell perfect so we're
going to probably look at the holy
sandals the last Buy price was about
757 and uh oh wow we got two the AL of
gods but let's get this in here holy
sandals
um so for 750 approximately we'll do
757k and uh it actually surprisingly
trades a lot for the holy sandal so
we're going to try five if we actually
look here at the G tracker history go
back to month actually trades 200 or 300
a day it looks like yeah it's quite
quite frequently for a clue scroll item
and uh we did get two a of the Gods and
we're selling those again for
oh boy what was it again uh oh yeah it
was 4300 almost we could sell them for
so pop those in there for 42
98k perfect now we'll probably wait for
these to start selling before we
consider buying more we're only 20
minutes in so I'm pretty surprised by
how quickly some of these items are
buying obviously not all of them work
and uh having enough offer slots is
going to be a bit of an issue I might
just consider taking these purple sweets
out because they don't really get us
much I mean let's just yeah let's just
sell them because we kind of need the
room for these larger scale flips all
right uh we're just going to instant
sell these purple sweets It's kind of
negligible the amount of money we're
getting from it anyway we uh probably
didn't lose
much
[__] oh my God I just lost 10 and 60k on
that wow well that really sucks so we'll
go ahead and try to get that money back
oh my God all right wizard boots going
in here for
584k all right guys though something
really excited came in we did sell one
of the Alee of the Gods now we bought
that for
4091 let's just get a calculator open
here so we bought it for 4091 and we
sold it for
4298 that is 207k in profit we just made
there so we just totally uh nulled that
derp all right guys so we sold the other
ale of the gods that is a
400k profit right there that is crazy I
haven't done this item in a while but
honestly when I do it I usually leave it
so I never really realize that this item
actually buys pretty quickly relatively
I mean it took 30 minutes to flip two uh
but why not go for another two anyway uh
so we'll go ahead and buy another set of
Al of the Gods same price put a two
quantity in and leave it okay so we
actually sold the holy sandal that is
going to be a 70k profit pretty nice and
uh we'll pull this other holy sandal out
that we did manage to buy as well uh
we're going to toss it in there for a
bit more I think uh cuz that did
instantly sell or not instantly sell but
it did sell pretty quickly uh so we'll
maybe try to get a 30k how about and uh
we also did sell some of with boots
which is nice we put another offer in
for another four so hopefully those
start coming through as well uh but
we're still getting about 30 or 27k or
something each boot uh which is not too
bad this is probably one of the higher
traded items that we actually managed to
get uh the purple suets [__] the purple
sweets okay guys so a couple things have
happened uh we did sell off our Fury
ornament kit and I see if we can still
have it there we bought it for oh okay
this there 2960 and we sold it for 3050
took about 30 minutes so we'll go ahead
and try to buy one more and hopefully we
can get that flipped in time we did buy
another ale of the Gods now I'm not sure
where to put it yet and oh we just
bought another holy sandal and I we'll
pop those two in there oh my someone
totally just checked the margin for that
I'm pretty sure anyway we sto it for 830
pop this other one in there for
825 just to [__] with that guy assuming
that is what happened and uh the wizard
boots we did get actually two more so
these are selling but not very quickly
so we're probably going to pull the bu
offer out for this one and pop them in
here for
583 uh cuz I that way to we kind of
[__] up there there way too many boots
to try to sell drop it down one more
just in case we can undercut on them and
that leaves us room to put in our ale of
the Gods for the massive profit that
they gave us last time of 27 K is it
still on there yeah we're selling it for
$42.98 okay so you bought another Fury
ornament kit for
2960 uh we'll sell it again for is it
3050 yeah
3050 and we also did sell another pair
of wizard boots so checking Along on
those ones we're getting about 25k in
profit in each one uh it's really fun to
watch every time something completes
it's like 100k in profit which is
awesome and yeah pretty happy how this
is going so far okay so we actually
bought the last armal page three and uh
we still have another one we're selling
for 475 it's been 20 minutes now so it's
been a little while uh so maybe we'll
pop down a little bit more to
470 uh cuz we do want these to sell we
do have 208 minutes though so we're
pretty much just halfway and yeah we
have 20 mil left maybe we'll try to find
another item okay how can I not do the
Robin Hood hat it is literally part of
my name so uh we looked it up it's a
about
1950 but we'll do
1951 and that we go for two cuz they not
do three cuz they do actually buy pretty
quickly and uh yeah I think that's going
to be our final item we're going to
focus on the ones we found so far cuz
they do seem to be working well okay so
we sold the fury ornament kit once again
uh for a decent profit uh 3050 we'll
probably go for one
more yeah we'll go for one more um but
we'll probably pull this the gods out
because I well if we end up selling this
we might buy it again but oh my God we
just bought all these Robin Hood hats
holy [__] okay we're going to sell these
for it wasn't a huge profit but still
pretty good 79 or 7 1879
sorry no that's incorrect oh she
K there we go but still a decent profit
on each boot or hat whatever all right
guys so we bought another Fury ornament
kit uh which it seems surprising to ever
buy an item like this but it does trade
I looked it up 150 an hour if you look
at the day uh every half an hour it's
getting two or three or in six uh so I
don't know it's definitely not
impossible to do a 1H hour flipping
challenge with items like this well this
is awkward it looks like we actually
just put in another offer in to buy a f
ornament kit for the wrong price so so
we should definitely take that out oh my
God such an idiot we're going to pop
that in for 30
50k and we also did sell those holy
sandals which is actually pretty nice
that was a I don't know 100K profit 757
we bought them for and we sold them for
825 not quite 100 but still pretty
respectable still okay so we sold off
our Fury ornament kit that is another
solid amount of profit there again we're
getting 90k on each kit now we only have
60 minutes left do we think we can do
another
one yes I we'll go for another Fury
ornament kit at 2960 just keep hitting
that button and we had to drop down
Robin Hood hats but they do sell pretty
quick uh we're only getting a 15K profit
on each one and which is not awful but
it's I wouldn't really do this item but
it does look cool so it's got that going
for it we are down to 13 minutes
remaining uh we did actually sell off
both of the armor little page 3s we had
to reduce it quite a bit uh probably
only
getting that's still not awful 20K or so
on each still and uh okay we just sold
all the Robin Hood hats at this point
we're just going to wait and hopefully
we sell this stuff because it'll be
important to get rid of as much of it as
possible because as you could see from
when I sold those purple suits uh you
have the potential to lose quite a bit
if you're going to instant sell the item
okay the wizard boots have totally sold
gold in
total I doubt our Buy offer was in here
but we got about 30k on each one so
probably 180k roughly uh from The Wizard
boots uh as a whole now we just have
these two left and
I this might sell probably not going to
sell this okay I'm an idiot this is a
Buy offer
again jeez guys you got you call me on
this stuff now all right guys we're just
about to finish this up it doesn't look
like this item is going to sell uh that
being said I think it was pretty
successful probably the most profitable
item was the AL of gods and would have
been more so had I sold this one uh the
ornament kits were quite good getting
70k on each and what else did we sell
here uh Robin Hood hats weren't super
great wizard boots they did trade
probably the quickest we probably trade
the most of them we stop this
timer and up every time but um uh they
didn't get as big a margin as the rest
of the items the holy sandals are
actually really good too we probably
flipped three of those for 80k profit
240 anyway guys let's see what we have
to sell this for this is going to be a
bit of a scary moment we bought it for
around 4 mil so we'll just see if we can
dump it for
that okay not so bad sold it for 489 it
will claim it and we're up to 41 mil
that is pretty exciting so we'll see how
much we made from 1 hour of flipping
clue scroll items we made 41 mil and
43k now like I said this is my third
attempt at this obviously this one was
the best it's a little bit Hit or Miss
depending on how the items are buying
some could come in three at a time or it
could be none would be traded at all
during the hour uh this time I ended up
working out I shuffled items around
tried different things and uh looks like
these items were some of the more
popular ones you can't always tell just
based on GE tracker OS buddy or whatever
uh tool you're using sometimes you kind
of have to just go with items that make
sense to actually be traded more often
anyway guys I hope you enjoyed and I
will see you guys in the next episode